where you were pandemic aspects die live
symbolism
many people are you have lost their jobs
and right now many europeans and working
the holiday the family without fans about
christmas
wine restrictive measures can slow down
the spread of device in the very
difficult situation
hoe all know that  only safe and
effective maxim your provider lasting
sustainable solution to this end and i
grab think you can help and is crucial to
end is and that i happened with that the
lock and here
up to date news and happy to announce
what marl
who want  taste new contract to
search hours see another cafe nineteen
work and love extreme portfolio
this contracts lau's store by up to afraid
of word 16 million boxes of the maxim
produced by modern
according to the results of clinical
trials see this way could be highly
effective against  i comb my team was
the vaccines in those trumps it safe and
effective and the member states will
receive it at the same time on a
project basis
at the same conditions modern nou hoe
het model now with is lust i can track
toe we have the pharmaceutical company
for arcam i my team often see a
portfolio
how you already working on get another one
body smoother setting up one of the most
comprehensive graphics my  team vaccine
portfolios in the world this provides
european access to the most promising
future actions under development so far
off course all actions of myportfolio
will be evaluated very carefully by
european medicines agency en moon die
will be on the otherwise
and placed on the market share save  and
if they are effective transparency scent
is crucial and the utmost importance
secure night live actions for joop 1
citizen is my live i bought our other
projects sametime
is to make sure where everyone has
access to do-box iens everywhere in the
world
the rush areas  affordable and
applicable
distribution of the vaccines this is why
we have pledged the 16 trillion
euros movies  test treatments and
diagnostics and vaccine against the corona
worldwide and test teamviewer how you
can tribute him from close to a hundred
million euros toe de
coiffeur saluti de comics the sealiti
that is responsible
and when he started frieze donations
here that from 100000000 by the  team
europe to make sure that loo and middle
entrance countries have access to the
vaccines third being produced nou en tim
future the aim is to save the world white
is maxim toe and the pandemic
how you already how the corner of your eye and the in this
spot waymarsh
[  Music]